I have a dream that's all I need
[Music]
I'll pay mistakes but mistakes make you
strong hi guys hey welcome to the LM
model lifestyle yes that's it
and this is our video for the 7th week
starting week 7 of the Body
Transformation series from fat to fit in
12 weeks
yep I'm Hannover it's this is my brother
Manny
hey guys all right all right now so far
we've already done a half up that whole
transformation right so we got six weeks
left but this is how Hannah did it so
far
Wow all right so you lost almost 11
kilos in the first six weeks yeah you
did it yeah it's good not dragging a car
around anymore 11 kilos I can't believe
it and we're going for 20 mmm so
hopefully they let us know how much you
guys lost as well you guys has been
following us from the start with this
whole body transformation series we'd
love to know as well and this week we're
gonna start doing it a hardcore we're
gonna change up the diet plan we're
gonna change up your workout routine as
well you ready for that
yeah yeah nice as I say do or die
there's a lot of fat still to lose
there's a lot of muscles in pain there's
a lot scuffing today yeah and let's come
what we're getting in through this one
is that right that's right that's right
that plan mostly we're gonna keep the
same but there's a big change coming in
how do is doing the instant method
fasting right you guys that don't know
what that is it's basically that you
don't eat anything for 16 hours and then
for eight hours you eat and just just
keep on doing that but we're gonna
change that up and we're gonna cut the
eating time and a half so I mean you're
used to eating for eight hours now it's
only four hours of eating every day yeah
by now you know why right do you know
how this whole intimate fasting things
work maybe you can explain to them as
well don't you understand it all right
nudity interfere with exhaustion so yeah
so whoa eight hours to four hours I
think it's good I think of eased into it
I was not talking to get used it yeah we
also have been reading up a lot of it
and of course you know why we're doing
it and so on but it's for me was
interesting I mean it's that's so the
big thing in your body a big hormone
that we're doing this for all just for
this home
it better be gradual is instrument and
answer then yeah so insulin right saw
was actually good thing but overloading
it is
laughing what we don't want to do so
what we're gonna do is we're going to
lower insulin hmm
every time you eat you basically you
spike insulin goes up because it we do
stuff in each the story in cells or it
leads the store in fact hmm and there's
also no losing the fact well I think
you've got a lot of insulin so the
insulin is up it by city it's a very
dominant hormone right yeah yeah yeah so
it blocks fat Wasser we need eat there's
not that force and going to happen until
insulin drops again yeah so by secure by
marrying that Simon when we've got high
insulin for a while eating we're
narrowing that down so that we have
water available when you're nothing to
you
yeah and if we go longer periods of
fasting our body kind of sometimes run
out of of carbohydrates and sugars and
so on of course these types of while
there's a couple of prerequisites for
that and so on but anyway the the gist
of it is it kind of switches fuel source
so your honor out of energy and switches
fuel source to fat yeah and then you
really start bleeding that fat yes it's
the same if you if you run for a like
Korres marathon over very far you've got
all that carbohydrates and sugars stored
up in your cells and so on and you've
got a lot about 2,000 calories talking
to the liver or something like that to
run out of that and then you switch a
little bit in fact times when you're
tossing wrong or starving in extreme
cases the body goes into fight or flight
mode by experimental science switches
over and you start using that fats and
it produces key testimony of brain your
brain can't work on sugar but it can
work on that alternate level from the
goethe ketones wait what it basically
produces fire fat when he means it over
so yeah to get into that factory burning
it you need to shorten appear an
interesting thing here is we get into
this habit of thinking we need food all
the time I threw for hours you get a
hungry
think you need to eat right but you just
become so used to it that you think you
do but for most people who are
overweight you already have all that
food fats in your body that is energy so
now we just really your body is learning
how to use that fat for energy and that
is how you lose it
right so instead of eight hours four
hours of eating time and the rest of it
no food alright so that's the biggest
thing with the diet plan to work out
routine this is what we're gonna change
the work of the team
how does buddy it's been six weeks right
so we tried to make it really fit so
he's muscles everything is fit and it's
ready for more right so we don't need to
make his whole body used to exercise
it's already used to it so now we're
gonna just kick it up a gear and we're
gonna really focus on building muscle a
little bit lean muscle alright so as
he's let's say this is the fact right
this is his muscles so his muscles is
underneath his layer of fat so you can't
really see it that well but as his fat
is gonna drop and we build his muscle
the muscle is gonna come out so you're
gonna start to see it so that's we gonna
start working on how do you feel about
that yeah I've been getting used to
weightlifting and white sand and to call
you and especially the hit core and so
on and I need them more and more
exciting to charge it up and get into it
and build pieces and so the good thing
is seeing that a little bit of a change
in huh so seeing them at the fat drop of
it and the muscle getting a little bit
that's those small changes you know it's
almost like in current I encouragement
motivation you know to keep on going and
so on yeah
so let's do it so this is one game
change of the work of your team
all right here we go this is day one
now we're gonna split the workout up in
three days now I'm not going to talk too
much like the previous videos but on the
top-left corner you see the type of
workout and the day it is on and then on
the lower left corner you see the
workout and also the amount of sets and
reps all right here we go enjoy the
workout
[Music]
is not about the number of reps you do
it's about the quality of reps you do so
always focus on doing it the right way
[Music]
they look at other people in the gym
focus because Fitness is not about being
better than someone else it's about
being better than you used to
no shortcuts no excuses work for it
[Music]
now remember if you master your mind you
will also master your body
the only bad workout is the one that
didn't happen
[Music]
focus on your goals don't just wish for
it work for it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
remember the pain you feel today will be
the strength you feel tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
your only limit is you remember push
yourself because no one else is going to
do it for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
too late forget you it's my let you go
[Music]
[Music]
so right
[Music]
that's it for the work of the team
alright so now that you guys know the
diet plan to work on your team I hope
you guys are ready for this are you
ready yeah are you happy
alright let's fast forward and let's see
how you did
done four kilos yeah suck it fat well
now for curiosity's gear that's almost
like a total of 15 kilograms that's a
lot right and I'd like to look a lot
different on the videos as well yeah
that's actually a lot of fact that we
get to record rough hmm especially in
the belly they are hard work but a lot
of it and I think we actually gained a
lot of muscle so I'm now thinking we've
if I need to like the roughly estimate
that's probably like three or three keys
that we gained in in muscle yeah lean
muscle beautiful like I think you'd like
something like 2% body fat down and so
on so yeah yeah but you know we were
working hard for it so I see it looks
better in the mirror as if that's the
kiss problem I think my devotion is
kicking in and so yeah yeah that's good
guys next week we're gonna kick things
up another notch we're gonna have some
interesting changes so don't miss it
if you liked the video give us a thumbs
up subscribe and we'll see you in the
next video Cheers
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]